bienvenue à Santa Clara que
fais-tu à l'usine nous fabriquons du papier ta
mère va travailler là-bas elle va c'est
ta nouvelle maison c'est un château
personne n'a vécu ici depuis des années il
y a 500 ans les conquistadors sont venus ici chercher
de l'argent et ont brûlé tous les enfants
de ce village vivant tu vas bien mais
nerveux j'ai l'impression que c'est le premier jour
d'école tu vas être génial alors il
peut déconseiller d'amener les enfants dans
un endroit avec de la vessie
que voulez-vous dire que quelqu'un a entendu
parler de sécurité et de garer les rebords
qu'exactement il sera là en disant que c'est un peu
difficile à expliquer mais notre fille
n'était pas seule elle a été emmenée par des
enfants
trouver